>>> WELCOME BACK.
SIX MONTHS AGO, THE TALIBAN TOOK
CONTROL IN AFGHANISTAN AFTER
U.S. TROOPS PULLED OUT AND ENDED
A DECADES LONG WAR.
SINCE THE TAKEOVER, WOMEN'S
RIGHTS HAVE DRASTICALLY
DETERIORATED.
WOMEN HAVE BEEN PREVENTED FROM
TRAVELING CERTAIN DISTANCES
WITHOUT A MALE RELATIVE, AND
MOST ARE STILL NOT ALLOWED TO
ATTEND PRIVATE SCHOOL.
UNIVERSITIES STARTED RE-OPENING
FOR WOMEN, BUT EVEN THOSE
CLASSES ARE SEGREGATED BY GENDER
AND MANY JOBS WILL NOT BE
AVAILABLE TO WOMEN ONCE THEY
GRADUATE.
OUR NEXT GUEST IS AN AFGHAN
SINGER AND SONG WRITER.
SHE'S ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S MOST
MOST FAMOUS ARTISTS AND A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
SHE'S URGING THE EU NOT TO
ABANDON THEM AND REJECT THE
TALIBAN AS A GOVERNMENT.
SHE JOINS ME LIVE FROM ISTANBUL
WHERE SHE FLED AFTER THE TALIBAN
REGAINED POWER.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
SIX MONTHS SINCE KABUL FELL AND
THE WORLD WITNESSED THOSE
HARROWING SCENES OF AFGHANS
TRYING TO FLEE THE TALIBAN.
YOU WERE OF COURSE ONE OF THEM.
WHAT ARE YOUR REFLECTIONS OF HOW
LIFE HAS CHANGED IN AFGHANISTAN
SINCE THEN, FOR WOMEN
ESPECIALLY?
>> OH, IT ABSOLUTELY FEELS LIKE
A NIGHTMARE.
WOMEN HAVE NO LIFE ANYMORE IN
THAT COUNTRY, TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE ANY ACCESS
TO EVEN THEIR BASIC RIGHTS.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO WORK.
GIRLS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GO TO
SCHOOL ANYMORE AFTER SIXTH
GRADE.
WOMEN ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GO TO
OFFICES OR WORK OR -- THEY HAVE
BASICALLY -- THEY HAVE NO LIFE,
AND THEY HAVE NOTHING TO LIVE
FOR.
AND IT'S SO HARD BREAKING, AND
IT'S SO SAD THAT DAY BY DAY
GETTING WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE.
AND MOST OF THEM -- WOMEN -- BY
THE WAY, WOMEN ARE NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO GO OUTSIDE WITHOUT A
MALE'S PRESENCE, WHICH IS REALLY
CRAZY, BECAUSE SO MANY WOMEN
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE -- FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY DON'T HAVE
HUSBANDS.
IF THEY NEED TO GO OUTSIDE OR DO
SHOPPING OR BUY FOOD FOR
CHILDREN, HOW ARE THEY GOING TO
GO OUT?
SO THE SITUATION IS QUITE BAD,
AND IT'S REALLY HEARTBREAKING
AND SAD.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY APPALLING,
AND YOU ARE IN A UNIQUE POSITION
OF BEING ABLE TO USE YOUR
PLATFORM.
I KNOW A FEW WEEK AGO AT THE
AFGHAN WOMEN'S DAYS IN BRUSSELS.
YOU ENTERED TO THE SOUND OF AN
AFGHAN WOMAN CRYING.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO DO THAT?
>> I DECIDED TO PERFORM THIS
SONG BECAUSE THIS SONG WAS
WRITTEN FOR THE RIGHTS OF AFGHAN
WOMEN AND HOW THE SITUATION IS
IN AFGHANISTAN.
AND RIGHT NOW, THIS IS THE
PERFECT PLATFORM FOR ME TO ONCE
AGAIN PERFORM THIS SONG TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE SITUATION OF
WOMEN IN SBOFGT AFGHANISTAN AND
THEY DON'T HAVE A VOICE OF THEIR
OWN, A IDENTITY, AND BASIC
RIGHTS.
AND THIS SONG HAS SOME EXTREMELY
POWERFUL -- AS WELL.
AND I WANTED TO RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THE WOMEN'S SITUATION AND
ASK THE WORLD, THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY, NOT TO RECOGNIZE
TALIBAN AS A GOVERNMENT UNTIL
AND UNLESS THEY GIVE AFGHAN
WOMEN THEIR FULL BASIC RIGHTS OR
HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> AND IT'S BITTER SWEET, ISN'T
IT?
BECAUSE YOU CAN USE YOUR VOICE
TO SING OUTSIDE OF AFGHAN, BUT
SO MANY CANNOT USE THEIR VOICES
INSIDE THE COUNTRY.
DOES THE MUSIC INDUSTRY AS YOU
KNEW IT EVEN EXIST ANYMORE?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
WE DO NOT HAVE A MUSIC INDUSTRY
ANYMORER BECAUSE MUSIC IS
COMPLETELY BAN IN THE
AFGHANISTAN.
I AM ONLY ABLE TO RAISE MY
VOICE, AS YOU SAID, BECAUSE I'M
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
INSIDE THE COUNTRY, ALL THE
SINGERS AND MUSICIANS THAT I
KNOW, THEY'RE ACTUALLY HIDING
INSIDE THEIR HOUSES.
THE MUSICIANS THAT I KNOW, THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY EVEN BROKEN THEIR
INSTRUMENTS BECAUSE THEY'RE SO
SCARED OF BEING CAUGHT WITH
THEIR INSTRUMENTS BY TALIBAN AND
BEING BEATEN UP OR IMPRISONED OR
WHATEVER.
AND SO MANY THISINGERS THAT I K
DO NOT HAVE FOOD TO EAT BECAUSE
THEY USED TO EARN THE BREAD OR
LIVELIHOOD FROM THEIR SKILL AND
THEIR ART, AND RIGHT NOW SINCE
THEY'RE NOT LIED TO SING ANYMORE
AND THERE'S NO PARTIES AND NO
CONCERTS, THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
FOOD FOR THE CHILDREN.
>> YOU HAVE SOME -- I WAS SAYING
EARLIER, 1.5 MILLION FOLLOWERS
ON INSTAGRAM.
WORLD FAMOUS, USED TO TRAVELING
GLOBALLY.
BUT FOR THE VAST NUMBER OF
AFGHAN REFUGEES IT HAS NOT BEEN
THAT EASY, LEAVING THEIR
COUNTRY, RESETTLING SOMEWHERE
NEW, AND THEY HAVE NOT ALWAYS
BEEN THAT WELCOME.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT FOR PEOPLE
TO OPEN THEIR MINDS AND THEIR
HEARTS TO AFGHAN REFUGEES AT
THIS TIME?
>> IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THE ONE THING THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IS ALL THE AFGHAN
PEOPLE, THEY LOVE THEIR COUNTRY,
AND IF THEY HAVE A CHOICE, THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY LIVE IN
AFGHANISTAN AND NOT ABROAD.
BUT BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN, YOU
KNOW, AT WAR FOR SO LONG, AND
RIGHT NOW LIVING IN AFGHANISTAN
IS ABSOLUTELY IMPOSSIBLE FOR A
HUMAN BEING.
DOESN'T MATTER WHO IT IS.
EVEN FOR MEN.
ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN.
IT'S NOT A COUNTRY, IT'S A HELL.
LIKE, YOU ARE IN PRISON.
YOU'RE A PRISONER OF THE
GOVERNMENT -- I DON'T RECOGNIZE
THEM AS A GOVERNMENT OF COURSE,
BUT TALIBAN.
SO IF THEY HAD A CHOICE, BELIEVE
ME, THEY WOULD STAY IN
AFGHANISTAN AND NOT TRAVEL TO
OTHER COUNTRIES, BUT NOW THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN FORCED TO LEAVE
TH